think may i
i think you just thought right what
about if my friend they're gonna get to
know that that's the first line
you can't really control who you like or
who you fall for but you can control how
you deal with the situation or how you
operate or how you choose to move
forward about questions
when you found out about the body count
were you repulsed
um
i wouldn't say repulse no because i just
don't really get that surprised in this
day and age like you know three figures
yeah i know did you hit it surprisingly
did you go there no why not
because it it never came about well if
it come about but you're still gone with
the three figures yeah yeah
yeah i would have hit like
i mean men can't undo their biology
they're biologically predispositioned to
want to spread their seed but they're
also biologically predispositioned to
want to want to ensure paternity so like
historically if a girl slept around they
don't know if the kid she's having is
his and that even still happens nowadays
like you see videos all the time where
this dude that's been raising a kid for
10 years finds out this kid is in his
and girls can do that legally there's no
ramifications
where if guys don't play child support
they go to jail but a girl can trap a
guy and
crazy so mori made a whole career off
that real [ __ ] yeah and so like guys
can't undo how they feel about it
i don't think like that automatically if
she
has a high body count
and if she is in a relationship she
actually you know love the men she's
been with she gonna sleep automatically
with someone else so easily that doesn't
honestly
we should like distinguish between when
you're single are you free to do
whatever you wish and when you are in
our relationship so it doesn't mean
you're going to be not loyal
do you know what i mean like it's more
it's more likely your habits are who you
are
okay why you need to label someone just
because yeah it's based on your it's not
based on your actions so it's same for
men so i would say men can actually is
actually allowed to have high body count
so what i what i supposed to think if
i'm actually going to marry the man
they're going to cheat on me
really don't care like women but women
don't women women don't care because
that's like i'm i'm a woman and i can't
as well no so women women don't care you
don't see girls lining up to date drake
and saying oh no his body counts too
high how will i get like no no but but
but the opposite of that brittany grant
grant or griner whatever her name is
like guys are like oh jesus christ oh no
no no no yeah because brittany and she's
beautiful
your habits like make up who you are so
if you've been doing something for a
decade how like just like if a guy
cheated on every single girl before you
he's probably going to cheat on you too
duh
personally for me if a guy's body count
is like the three figures i'd be just as
disgusted don't matter if he's drake
chris but i don't care i'd be repulsed
to be honest
if it's 50 depending on how old he is
again i'd still feel a bit icky is it oh
yeah no you're gonna be icky would you
want to marry a virgin
i wouldn't mind you wouldn't mind
marrying a virgin you'd want to like
tell him what to do i wouldn't mind
because it's not
it's not an issue for me if he ticks
every single box and then it turns out
he's a virgin
to me i wouldn't i wouldn't be fast
could you name could you name five of
your boxes
name five of my boxes
so
ambitious
god fearing like prayerful
um
loyal as well
funny sort of sense of humor
and
i can't think of a fifth one when you
say ambitious is there a dollar amount
no ambitious like driven wanting
something for himself and not just so if
he's making how old are you so you're 31
35 35 how old would you date
the oldest i would date yeah
probably 40. so if he's 40 and he still
makes 30 000
i don't know the conversion like 30 000
us dollars which would be like 20 20 20.
like 20 000 um 20 000 pounds would you
be cool with that he's 40. he's had time
to get there
if he's if he's trying to get somewhere
and he's not just what if he gets what
if he gets nowhere
because i'd i'd sense that he's not
ambitious and it would put me off right
but i think like a lot of times it's
kind of disingenuous to guys because
girls will say there's no price but you
you have one in your head and there is a
price either has to be working towards
that like towards it or there but if he
doesn't get there within a certain
amount of time you're ghost you're gone
no but
you can't really put a time frame on i'm
giving you a time to become successful
but no i'm saying and you might not know
even to want to get there and actively
trying to get there does that make sense
you might not know it like like you
might not have thought about it but like
in some level you're not going to date a
bum forever so if he if he's
i wouldn't have if he's a bum
and he's not ambitious i wouldn't be
attracted to him
yeah but i'm saying there's a there's a
doll there's a minimum dollar
so
okay would you date a guy that's
homeless with no job i wouldn't meet a
guy that's homeless with my job where
would i meet you you pass them every day
but why would i approach you probably
or how would that work right but i'm
saying you there's a minimum requirement
you have
not just related to like mom is that a
bad thing no it's not a bad thing i
don't think i don't think we should date
bombs what i'm saying like you're
avoiding the question what was the
question
what's the minimum amount of money you
need a guy to make
i don't know more than me i don't know
it's the same as me or more okay what's
roughly you don't have to
i don't want to say my how much i make
but the same as me or more thus you
can't make less than you right basically
yeah okay why not well i'm not saying he
can't but i would prefer i'm saying what
i prefer is if he was the same level as
me or making more if he's making less a
bit less and actively trying to
progress within his career then there's
nothing wrong with that i can't just
help something he said about the boxes
what are your boxes and it was the
virgin
you said you're taking a virgin virgin
wasn't the book
no she said she said
what are your boxes when he said about
yeah she no woman ever says sex
if it was a man wouldn't that be one of
your boxes
you know you said that if he was over
and he ticked your boxes yeah as a man
wouldn't sex be one of your top boxes
i'm just asking as in would i marry a
virgin
no are you getting sex with this
you know you said every man every woman
ticks all your boxes right isn't sex one
of your boxes
um
do you think did you never could you
have a happy relationship
without having that box sticks without
having sex or without having good sex
good sex
yeah i could still have a
pretty successful relationship not me
yeah so youtube you have that you
hesitated i don't believe you yeah i
mean i don't that's one of my main boxes
i don't know because i'm saying
everybody's talking about oh i want to
be nicer compatible
but you won't know that until you have
sex with him that's what i wouldn't say
that's why when women say they want to
have a virgin to me
i teach in a nothing
do you know what i mean because i ain't
got time if i'm a virgin he's a virgin
fine but i am not gonna go and pick up a
virgin
f sex is one of my boxes and sex is one
of my boxes it should be a man's box too
because if you're not getting good sex
from your woman go elsewhere safely for
women i'm sorry but how could that's why
they got sex marriages out there yes how
can you be having like you be oh yeah
i'm happy because sex is not one of my
boxes she knows that sex take one of
your boxes then when the sex is gone
what are you gonna do then say oh but i
like her personality
[ __ ] i have a question do you think it's
fair for women to expect monogamy from
men if they gave their best years to
another man
umi yeah like